can you describe what your  antidepressant withdrawal looked like  what symptoms did you have one day I was  I was living in New York City at the  time and I was walking on Park Avenue  and it had just started to rain all of a  sudden like in one moment all of my  senses intensified like I saw the light  bulb like come into focus and all the  lights from the taxis coming at me went  from round orbs into really sharp stars  and everything got super loud and then  my skin started really hurting with the  rain the rain was coming down and it  felt like bullets on my skin and I was  just so overwhelmed by this sensory  feeling and that's the first time I  realized that something something big is  about to happen to me and these drugs  were doing a lot more than just keeping  my depression at Bay which is what I  assumed was the only effect that they  were having I realized in that moment  that they were having an effect on my  entire physical system